Nói lặng người nghe nghe ăn, ín đau cũng thấy bịch thử auto, đi phủ đêm không sử.
Sẽ tháp, sẽn châu, về mạnh đất sự nghệ hoa thăm sạm sẽn tháp,
hình sẽn châu, chẳng ai là không biết, nơi đẹp quá nổi tiếng với độ sòn có,
nếu như trước khi, sẽn tháp được quyền gọi cái tên là nặng đúng đắt,
thì nay, với những mọi bịch thử tên tì mật sán sát, chở thành làm bịch thử.
Theo thông kê, toàn sạm có trên một nghiên người tưởng sế lặng ăn, bốn bản tại lào,
có khoảng 4 mi hợp ra đình thành lập cất tại li領 nhỏ để tu có mật hàng của cấp sân lào.
Từ ngày bốn bản đường nát, sả dễn tháp trường thành một chung liệu sát sọn nhất của tình nghi ăn,
hiện có hàng chăm hộ rào, sử biệt thử đêm không sửi.
Chứ kể hàng chăm chức auto ra đình trong đó có hàng chục auto tiền đi.
Đối thành, kinh thành, sát đối thành, kinh in thành nghi ăn,
sưa vốn là một phủng đất nghiệp khó, phục sống người dân chủ yếu sự khó kê đối,
tuy nhiên đưa thành thục phủng đất chủ, khoảng 5 cập cũng đêm rất mọi nhiều hơn được.
Tuy nhiên, bánh giả này đã đời đời đời ký xuất ngoại.
Được biết, sát đối thành có trên 3 trong tí vũ, khoảng 2 nghiên người nhà thứ 2 để vũ tần,
trên 2 trong sự auto các loại, sơ biệt đối thành, nếu như được tự tiền đi,
sây hơi hàng sang mà thốt lên nặp nhiên thì qua là sư diễn trái đất.
Lâm vĩnh ngoà, tiền thành, không ai nhiều gió nghề bánh trường người làm vĩnh ngoà,
sơ hực thành, in thành xuất hiện của thế vào thời gian nào, nhưng theo lời các cuộc ông cũng bà trong lãng kể lại,
thì tư các thời gian trang một số nhỏ lại các bà các trị trong lãng,
hăng này có làm phải bà chục chức công khán mằng ra trực bán,
là nhắc đến lãng với hòa, rất nhiều người sẽ nhờ đến nơi đây chính là lãng tí phủ bánh trường đổi tiếng ngồi sự nghệ,
tư bánh trường. Người sân nơi đây có tu nhập khoảng 4 trợ đồng một ngày,
cũng có hợp xa đình tu về được trên xe bố mấy trợ đồng một ngày từ xo bánh trường,
bánh tết bánh ra trong 10 tết.